How does the human brain build itself?
How do circuits in the human brain
wire together?
For instance, how does one tiny neuron
in the outer layer of the brain
send a thin axon
all the way to the spinal cord,
find the right neuron
and then control muscle contraction
as we extend a hand
and grasp a glass of water?
I'm here to tell you
that we can finally grow
parts of the human brain
from any individual
and then build functioning human circuits
in a laboratory cell culture dish.
These clumps of neural tissue
are known as brain organoids.
And when we put them together to form
circuits, they become “assembloids.”
Assembloids could be key to understanding
how the human brain is built.
Today, most of what we know
about the human brain
comes from studies in animals,
typically mice.
And while we've learned a lot
from these animal brains,
the characteristics
that make the human brain unique,
and uniquely susceptible to disease,
remain mysterious.
I’m a physician by training
and a professor at Stanford,
where my laboratory has been taking
unconventional approaches
to study how the human brain develops,
how disorders in the human brain arise
and find new ways of treatment.
I think the best way to explain,
though, how we do this
is through the eyes of one of my patients.
When I opened my lab at Stanford,
Eduard, who's on the autism spectrum,
sent me this drawing
depicting how he thought
we were studying brain disorders.
Now to paraphrase him, he said,
"What I think you're doing
is you're climbing up a ladder,
poking holes in people's brains
and then use tiny telescopes
to watch neural cells."
Of course, that's not what we do.
So I called him up, explained the process,
and then the next morning
he sent me another drawing,
which I think ended up
being a quite accurate representation
of the work that we
and many others now are doing.
Again, to paraphrase him, he said,
"You're taking skin cells
from patients that have
specific brain disorders,
then doing some mumbo jumbo to the cells
to push them back in time
and turn them into stem cells."
And then he knew that stem cells
can be coaxed to become any cell type.
“So then you’re taking them
and turning them into brain cells
that form brain circuits.”
That's right. We can build
human brain circuits in a dish.
How is that possible?
Building on the hard work of biologists
over the past 15 years or so,
we can today take any cell type
from any individual
and then push it back in time
to turn them into stem cells
and then guide those stem cells
to become any other cell type.
We start by asking a patient
to provide a small skin sample.
We then take those skin cells,
reprogram them
by putting a series of genetic factors
and push them back in time
so that those skin cells
become stem cells.
It's like cellular alchemy.
These stem cells
have almost magical abilities
to turn into any other cell type.
So what do we do?
We take the stem cells,
we dissociate them,
we then aggregate them
so that they form spheres
or tiny balls of cells.
We then take those,
move them into a special plate
where there is a kind of chemical soup.
And that chemical soup
will allow them to grow
and transform
and turn into a brain organoid.
By providing different cues,
we can turn this brain organoid
to resemble specific regions
of the central nervous system.
For instance, we have a recipe
that allows them
to become a cerebral cortex,
the outer layer of the brain.
By using a slightly different
combination of factors,
we can turn them into a spinal cord.
The secret to this process
is careful guidance.
In the end, they look like this.
Tiny clusters of brain cells
at the bottom of a dish.
And let me be clear.
This are not brains in a jar.
(Laughter)
These are parts of the nervous system
in a laboratory dish.
Each of them contains millions of cells,
and we can even listen
as they fire electrical signals.
(Electrical signals firing)
Or we can watch them
as they sparkle with electrical activity.
Or we can image inside and watch the cells
as they communicate with each other.
Isn't it remarkable to think
that just a few months ago
these cells were skin cells in a patient,
and now they are neural cells
at the bottom of a dish
that we can study at ease.
(Applause)
Thank you.
So with these models of brain growth,
we started wondering: Could we use them
to start to understand disease?
So for instance, we wanted to know,
could we understand how low oxygen
impacts the brains of premature babies?
So to do this, we took brain organoids
and put them in a special incubator.
We then lowered the concentration
of oxygen and watched them.
We discovered something quite interesting.
Only one specific cell type
was affected by the low oxygen.
That cell type is responsible
for the expansion of the human cortex.
We found exactly how that happens
and even found the drug
that could prevent that process.
These clumps of three-dimensional tissue
can be grown in a dish for years.
In fact, we've maintained
the longest cultures
that have been reported to date,
going beyond 800 days.
At nine to 10 months,
which is the equivalent of birth,
they slowly transitioned, and they started
to resemble the postnatal brain.
We have discovered a brain clock
which keeps track of time
in a dish and outside of the uterus.
Understanding the molecular mechanisms
that underlie this brain clock
could be key to finding new strategies
to either accelerate or decelerate
or rejuvenate human brain cells.
The work that I've shown you so far
is pioneering not just because
of what it teaches us
about the human brain,
but also because
of the frontiers of ethics.
Organoids and assembloids
are not full replicas of the human brain.
They're not brains in a jar.
They're not minibrain.
They're not some stepping stone
to a Frankenstein monster.
They have no blood flow,
they receive no meaningful
inputs and outputs.
But at one point,
they may become more complex.
At one point, they may
receive sensory input.
So as the science advances,
we in the scientific community
have been very careful
about discussing what are
some of the ethical questions,
the societal implications
and potential regulations.
Most of the work
that I’ve shown you so far
has been in one specific brain region.
But to really understand circuits,
we actually need to build
more complicated brain circuits.
And so to do this, six years ago,
we came up with a new approach
to build human circuits
called an assembloid.
Assembloids are essentially
blocks of tissue
that we build in a dish
from multiple organoids put together.
When we put two brain organoids together,
we discovered something
really fascinating.
First, they fused to each other.
But then they started to communicate,
and brain cells from one side
started to slowly migrate
onto the other side
and form circuits,
much like they would in the actual brain.
In fact, we can even watch them live
as they move from one side to the other.
I still remember how we were
in the lab in absolute awe
when we saw for the first time
how human cells undergo
this peculiar jumping behavior.
This is all fascinating,
but what is it actually good for?
Dysfunction in the human brain
causes brain disorders,
such as autism and schizophrenia
and Alzheimer's disease,
devastating conditions
that are poorly understood.
Nearly one in five individuals
suffers from a psychiatric disease.
What is even more striking
is that the lowest success rate
for finding new drugs
is in psychiatry,
out of all the branches of medicine,
likely because until now
we couldn't really access the human brain.
Using brain organoids and assembloids,
we can create avatars
for a patient's brain development
and then use those to dissect
the molecular mechanism of disease.
Let me give you one example.
As you have seen,
assembloids can be used
to model this healthy
jumping behavior of neurons.
So what we did is we created assembloids
from patients with Timothy syndrome,
which is a rare genetic disease
associated with autism and epilepsy.
When we looked inside the assembloids,
we noticed something remarkable.
The cells were moving much faster,
but every time they would jump,
they would jump a shorter distance.
So in the end, they would be left behind.
Over the past six years
in extensive studies,
we've actually dissected
the molecular mechanism of this defect
and even found ways of restoring it.
And we're excited to be moving towards
a potential therapeutic avenue
in the next year or so.
(Applause)
The promise of organoids and assembloids
is that they will slowly allow us
to gain new insights
into the hidden biology
of the human brain.
And by doing so,
they could revolutionize the way we think
about human brain development, evolution,
function and disease.
So what's next?
Well, to really be able to gain insight
into more complex brain disorders,
we need to build more complex circuits.
So in the last minute, let me show you
the most complicated circuit
we have built to date.
The circuit that controls
voluntary movement.
To do this, we've created three organoids.
One, shown here in purple,
that resembles the cortex.
One, in yellow,
that resembles the spinal cord,
and one, in red,
that resembles human muscle.
We then put them together
and watched them fuse
and noticed something really spectacular.
Neurons on the cortical side
started extending axons,
find spinal motor neurons
in the spinal side,
connect with them,
and then those farther project
and connect to muscle.
When we put a light stimulus
on the cortical site,
we noticed the muscle
on the opposite side contract.
We have modeled for the first time
a human cortical motor pathway.
(Applause)
And let me be clear.
These cells find each other.
Unlike in engineering,
we don't have a master plan,
we don't provide a plan
because the human brain builds itself.
And then in itself,
it's a remarkable opportunity
to try to reverse engineer
what are some of the steps
that underlie human brain development?
I know that this all sounds
science fiction,
but we now do this routinely in the lab.
We have derived thousands and thousands
of organoids and assembloids
from patients with various
neuropsychiatric diseases,
including, for instance,
infecting them with viruses
such as polio virus
to understand how diseases arise.
The statistician George Box famously said,
"All models are wrong,
but some are useful."
(Laughter)
I do the work that I do
because the promise and hope
of brain assembloids and organoids
is that by allowing us
to recreate circuits of the human brain,
we will gain new insights
into human biology.
And this in itself will open a new era
in the treatment of brain disorders.
Thank you.
(Applause)